le maire de New York aujourd'hui en
réaction à l'annonce par le couple Harry
et Megan de cette poursuite qui aurait
duré deux heures à New York et le maire
soulève quand même certains doutes tes
deux heures dans les rues de New York
c'est long longtemps ils ont été
pourchassés par des paparazzis à travers
ces rues un événement qui nous rappelle
les circonstances de la mort de la
princesse Diana la mère de Harry
surveillée à Paris en août 97 ça fait
quand même 26 ans et mon invité à
Martine Saint-Victor elle est stratège
en communication directe règle Montréal
une amie d'émission bonsoir Martine
bonsoir Marie d'abord on connaît pas le
fil des événements on parle d'allégation
d'avoir quel est l'intérêt du couple de
divulguer du soir dont on n'avait pas
encore parlé avec un accent très
dramatique en quasi chaotique ou ça
aurait pu faire des blessés ça aurait pu
être fatal en fait le maire de New York
était assez
pas du tout ému par cette par cette
histoire je crois que le couple a décidé
de sortir cette histoire ses propres
termes utilisant ses propres mots parce
que c'est son expérience comme il y a eu
des témoins c'est une histoire qui
allait sortir de toute façon en même
temps on remet un doute une poursuite de
deux heures
il faudra un moment donné avoir le fil
complet des événements par des témoins
crédibles vous savez la BBC ce soir à
une interview avec le chauffeur de taxi
qui parce que le couple est parti de sa
voiture privée et à sauter dans un taxi
de New York pour essayer de
d'esquiver si on veut les paparazzis
donc oui on va on va remettre le fil du
temps sauf que pour moi ce qui s'est
passé hier soir révèle un petit peu ce
qu'on savait déjà c'est à dire qu'ils
sont toujours pour chasser
Harry et Megane ont demandé une sécurité
royale entre guillemets qu'ils n'ont pas
obtenu c'est à dire que Harry et Meghan
paix de leur propre poche leur sécurité
donc c'est une preuve qu'il y a encore
une demande pour ce couple et puis une
autre preuve aussi que il souhaite on
parlait le contrôle du message de cette
nouvelle il y a le contrôle de leur
image aussi alors vous savez ils étaient
à une soirée un peu plus tôt hier qu'ils
ont quitté à 22h et ils ont posé pour
des photographes mais en sortant de ce
lieu de ce lieu privé il ne souhaitait
pas être pris en photo en se rappelle
qu'on les a pas vu ensemble depuis
depuis un petit moment et on sait
pourquoi c'est parce que c'est un couple
qui comprend la valeur de son image si
on regarde l'épisode leur documentaire
sur Netflix on a vu plein de photos
qu'on n'avait jamais vu pourquoi parce
que le couple est capable de comprendre
la valeur ici quand justement dévoiler
ce genre
il y a des procès à Londres dans
lesquels Harry est impliqué notamment
justement pour soi pour du piratage ou
bon notamment contre le Méru
on le sait très préoccupé sinon obsédé
par les effets
mentale sur les circonstances de la mort
de sa mère cela dit eux-mêmes
par Netflix par cette série par le livre
eux-mêmes utilisent les médias et c'est
comme si ils sont pas capables
d'accepter les effets d'avoir nourri
leur ils ont besoin comme de faire
pendant cette notoriété puis quand elle
arrive ils sont ils acceptent pas les
conséquences mais ils ont le droit alors
ça on peut en débattre mais ils ont le
droit ce ne sont pas des élus ce sont
quand même des personnes privées je
pense que on peut faire en parallèle
avec la relation de Diana et la presse
c'est-à-dire que à un moment elle a
compris le pouvoir qu'elle avait elle a
changé sa stratégie elle a dit je vais
utiliser la presse quand c'est bon pour
moi et c'est un peu un modèle c'est
devenu un modèle d'affaires qu'on a vu
reproduire qu'on voit aujourd'hui
finalement en fait ce qu'il a tué c'est
parce que justement elle contrôle la si
bien son image que la valeur de photos
de Diana or non contrôlée avec c'était
très élevé regardez en 2006 une photo de
Kate Middleton s'est vendu à 25 dollars
alors c'est pour vous montrer qu'il y a
une valeur importante et ce que le
couple dénonce c'est en fait ce
modèle d'affaires qui n'est pas basé sur
leur contrôle mais au contraire qui est
basé à qui aura cette photo unique et
puis là ils étaient à New York dans la
capitale mondiale des médias donc
évidemment c'est pas c'est plus c'est
plus complexe de d'essayer de rester
privé en même temps ça a été mentionné
aujourd'hui New York en avait d'autres
vedettes oui pourquoi eux et pas les
autres parce qu'ils ont ils ont les plus
grandes stars du monde ils ont même les
chefs d'État les chefs de gouvernement
les Nations Unies sont là je crois pas
qu'une photo d'Antonio gutérus
et puis New York historiquement à
toujours donner si on veut lui à des
photos
iconiques rappelez-vous de Jackie on
assise quand elle sortait de son
appartement prise en photo par Juan
galila ça s'est retrouvé dans un musée
quand même champ de Pen qui se battait
avec un journaliste une photo quand même
qui est devenue iconique tout ça ça se
passe dans les rues de New York parce
que New York c'est un peu c'est un peu
Los Angeles c'est un peu Paris c'est un
peu donc on sait que c'est une ville qui
offre des si on veut des des mises en
scène uniques c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une valeur additionnelle pour cette
photo la question que je me suis posée
aussi ça a été pris 2 heures dans le
trafic comment ça se fait qu'ils ont pas
appelé la police tout de suite ah oui
par contre ils se sont rendus dans un
faisant
le district 19 parce que c'est étonnant
deux heures donc est-ce que ça pourrait
en même temps être un effet boomerang
c'est-à-dire que s'il y a des fêtes dans
leur version ça pourrait effectivement
leur nuire parce que deux heures dans
les rues de New York et pourchasser
comme je disais tout à l'heure ça soit
des questions peut-être que le mot est
fort mais mais la réalité demeure que
ils ont dû pendant deux heures essayer
de déjouer de paparazz que je trouve
drôle aujourd'hui avec
la réaction qu'on a de plusieurs c'est
que on leur fait procès déjà et ça ça
montre que il y a une ils ont perdu
mais on sait pas ce qui sont cette
paparazzi parce qu'il y a pas cette
tradition là que tu apparaissait aussi
harcelant à New York comme en
Grande-Bretagne oui mais n'oubliez pas
que lorsque le couple était avant
couvert les paparazzis qu'ils avaient
épi était des pas-parisis anglais alors
les gens voyagent les paparazzis anglais
voyage avec Mégane et Harris
c'est-à-dire suivre leur agenda et se
rendre où le couple sera aussi en tout
cas ça fait jaser
merci merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI